the show is blackish Tuesdays 9:00
Eastern on a ABC also an animated film
Ferdinand opens in theaters December
15th Anthony Anderson joins us right
let's get the serious stuff out of the
way please
the name blackish
when did somebody first come up with
blackish uh in in a meeting that I had
with my partner Kenya who actually
created the show five years ago years
ago five years ago when did you say that
you were Jewish you know you go every
week no just basically I'm you know the
main holidays will go and then I said
something a little if I guess that makes
me do is you could be well can you steal
can you sample in TV no you can't is it
called stealing that name almost not
happen was there any concern that it was
network TV that you know that the
studios are executives got into it okay
interesting question but why wouldn't
that name happen I don't know that's why
I see just PC culture yeah I know that's
that's what I'd like to ask because
they're there there was people were in a
little uproar about the name and and I
didn't understand why but we were always
going to keep that name and we thought
maybe we might have had a fight with ABC
because after they purchased the project
and we were developing
they never referred to it as blackish
after that moment they were you know my
parking spot had a plaque on it and
every email that came to us with notes
above the show said the untitled Anthony
Anderson project after they bought black
is not one time did they ever refer to
it as that and we thought we were gonna
have to have a fight about that and so
we were just trying to pick our fights
because we knew we wanted this one and
when when we made our pilot and they
they decided to pick the show up they
said by the way we're going to keep the
name yeah but you understand though
everybody has a problem with everything
now and everybody's nervous in network
TV now this was on Netflix or Amazon or
Hulu no one would care no but network TV
then it feels like wait a minute are
they allowed to say that yeah yeah and
and I don't know if you get more people
curious because of the name that they'll
watch because of the name I don't know
if that market studies focus possibly
could be but you know yeah it was never
a marketing ploy or marketing to for us
this this is what this is what our show
was called and and you look at it now
and II couldn't be called anything else
well we're gonna call it the Johnston's
[Music]
what was your first paid acting job my
first oh man
okay my first paid acting gig I was a
mascot for gourmet dessert delivery
company while I was in college and I had
to act as a mascot and and my mascot
uniform was a pair of glitter Chuck
Taylor all-stars high atop some black
dance tights that glitter gloves a
glitter Lone Ranger mask and a pink cape
that on the back said captain cravings
first paid I can gig but is that where
you brag hey I'm an actor what's the
coolest job you ever had
the coolest job I've ever had doing what
I'm doing right now is Andre Johnson on
blackish yeah because I get to tell
personal stories every week
you know not just mine but but you know
all of ours you know we have a
remarkable riding staff and just the
things that we get to talk about and do
want on that show uh you were on the
shield
you got a couple years yes to season
Antwon Mitchell two seasons yeah how
intense was that man I think uh for me I
thought that was some of the best work
that I had done as an actor on that show
I'm a pretty intense there are some
scenes that were uncomfortable yeah yeah
to two reasons one I was working
obviously gluing clothes and Michael
Chiklis my first season and two I kind
of had something to prove as as an actor
that you know you know Hollywood can be
myopic in their thinking at times and if
you do something well that's all they
see you as and I had done the majority
of my work as as a comedic actor so I
had something to prove with going that
dark comedian you liked growing up with
ooh oh wow moms Mabley Redd Foxx you
know Richard Pryor Eddie Murphy yeah but
was there something you saw and you go I
that's what I want to do there's usually
a moment where you go you know what you
know my moment you know watching my
mother my mother's a horrible actress
and she knows now she is because I paid
forty five plus years but no my I I
remember there was only three things I
wanted to do as a kid I wanted to play
football for the Dallas Cowboys
be a lawyer or be an actor and at the
age of nine I realized that if I became
an actor I could become all three of
those things and everything else I
wanted to be in life and I was in the
back of Compton Community College
theater I'm the oldest of my siblings so
it was just three boys at the time just
me and my two brothers in the back and
my mother was on stage during a
production of A Raisin in the Sun and I
looked up and said that's what I'm gonna
do with the rest of my life that's cool
yeah that was okay so you were a Cowboy
fan
but now you're a Raider fan yeah you
know Kip hey man I grew up in the 70s
man you know that was America's team
back then
so yeah Raiders were still pretty good
back then yeah they were but for some
reason as a kid my dad's from Little
Rock Arkansas Dallas was his team so you
know I grew up with you know that
started in the house and then I found my
team which was the Raiders who did we
have was an ice cube when I said how
would it go over if I went into Compton
and and Cuba be cool a brother's
[Laughter]
[Music]
favorite cowboy growing up favorite
cowboy growing up too tall Jones because
names back then baseball again remember
when nicknames were nicknames not a
derivative of your name exactly exactly
Finch the Steel Curtain the purple
people eater yeah yeah nothing like it
no that was good all day and you became
a clipper fan not a Laker apologist you
know what I was I'm a sports fan let me
say that first I'm a sports fan and I
have friends that play on certain teams
so I grew up a Laker fan and then the
the Laker organization became unfamiliar
to me I thought you know I thought I
didn't recognize the team and I stuck
with him for a while and then I had
season tickets for the Lakers and the
Clippers one year and then I just my
affinity for the Clippers just started
to grow a little bit more who are your
friends
Who am I free I don't name drop like
that damn I don't know
just give me one the Chris Paul Chris
Paul okay yeah is he gonna play again
any time I hope so man I mean no longer
clipper but uh I wish him health man
yeah you don't ever want to see an
athlete go down and and not play well
yeah but if he comes back and play when
he plays the Clippers who you rooting
for
I got a roof with my Clippers okay you
want Chris to do well I want to do what
you want the Clippers to win yeah yeah
and and the Clippers need a win right
about now um
you think of Balmer as a dancer you look
at your owner over there dancing what do
you think when you see Steve Ballmer how
is LeBron is an actor the movie trainer
[Laughter]
honest in his work man it was refreshing
the scene is there an athlete who you
think could be a great actor a lot of
these cats could be good I don't know
man
no Charles Barkley hey you said athlete
I'm sorry but it's Charles acting now or
as Charles just be now Charles is being
Charles Harrison Ford is Harrison Ford
in every movie yeah yeah the story that
you pushed on blackish that they said no
you can't do it oh wow they have it man
did you see the season-opening we did a
slave episode of that you know they we
we've done some good things no they
haven't said no to anything has has
Netflix Hulu Amazon opened the doors a
little more for network to allow a
little more a little more creativity or
do you think it's still by the book I
think network television is is by the
book mainstream but and and and and
saying that it still grows it still
grows with the culture and with society
because we're pushing the envelope and
in brought not us in general on our show
but as actors and entertainers the the
envelope continues to get pushed and
broadcast cast television so yeah it's
it's expanding and growing with us the
animated movie Ferdinand that's opens
December 15th this does yes it does
what's number 15th and
what role do you play here I play bones
the skinny bull that nobody wants nobody
wants the skinny bull
so Ferdinand the bull yeah Ferdinand the
bull played by John Cena and you got me
playing bones and we're best friends
Cena is a talented talented guy uh-huh
yes could you ever get in the ring with
him could I ever get in the ring with
him yeah I could run for a fan you gotta
catch me first
were you at WWE WWF WWF you were I go
back to days of George the animal Steele
steals me Superfly Snuka you know Andre
the Giant I loved like Andre to the
Giant just fascinated me and then you I
think there's a 34:30 or Bill Simmons is
gonna do a film on Andre the Giant of
just like his diet like how much he ate
how much you drink a case of beer that
big when you drink a case of bad least
and it's not like you go you know is
this show I'm putting on a little weight
here I mean right weighed 450 pounds
there yeah and I was still considered
like that was too but we got to watch
what we eat man and that's what brings
me to New York right now you know
talking about there's no secret that I'm
a type 2 diabetic so we talked about
that on our show blackish my character
Dre being diagnosed as a type 2 diabetic
so we've did an integration and a
partnership with novo nordisk first
integration of its of its kind like that
to deal with an issue like this with
this lead character and so we've come up
with a campaign get real about diabetes
calm that people can go to to learn how
to manage their disease what to look out
for it and how to take care of
themselves and there's a Facebook page
and so we're here just to spread the
word right now about that cool give us
that address again if people have more
one more you know about diabetes dot-com
yeah and and and and you can go on
Facebook and do the same thing get real
about diabetes and keep an eye out on
the spin off to blackish called Jewish
can I get it can I get an executive
producer credit
we're partnership baby we're partnership
I think we could sell this I think we
could sell this if not Tyler Perry on
line one Gaetano Perry Tyler Perry could
make anything right Tyler Perry could
make anything
he has a following to make anything man
oh yeah Madea Madea and Jewish somehow
we make that work there the movie
Ferdinand in theaters December 15th
blackish
Tuesday 9:00 Eastern on ABC and the
diabetes website is get real about
diabetes calm thank you for coming in
thanks for having me great to have you
guys read for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]